all right switching gears to talk about
our beautiful weather blue skies and we
got to say thank you to ted florento for
this great forecast yeah amazing it's
like southern california weather i've
been putting down all the windows
because you always say let the fresh air
in why not all right right for this time
of year we went through such a brutal
summer that this just feels nice outside
it always feels like a question for you
do i smell like chips right now
you mean because it's nacho day and you
were next door chowing
las down now las vegas now has all that
food next door
is right there because he's not sharing
he has them over there i apologize i
wear all this cologne and then i smell
like nacho daddy right now
you're not kidding though a gorgeous day
today and i did the same
kg i pulled down my windows i opened the
sunroof because it just it's so nice out
there and you'll get that chance also
for that afternoon commute as well
mainly clear skies we started off with
clouds but i said as the day progressed
that we would get
some sunshine and that's what we're
looking at right now unfortunately with
the unseasonably mild temperatures we
still have a little bit of pollen out
there elm right now reporting moderate
readings this could be why you're
sniffling and sneezing of course ragweed
and sagebush looking good right now air
quality is also good dust has settled
right now no ozone problems 79 degrees
at sky canyon centennial hills these are
your curtain neighborhood temperatures
north las vegas at 78 closer to 80 for
sunrise manor 78 whitney ranch 75
mountains edge and southern highlands at
74.
76 for you joining us from anthem at
this four o'clock hour 79 currently for
prompt along with mesquite and you're in
the 80s 84 degrees specifically for you
in laflin yesterday
we had all that cloud cover when i was
live and then this morning we saw those
clouds look at that all that is passed
off right now got some high thin clouds
coming in from the west but that's also
our radar there's no rain here in the
desert southwest all that's way up in
the pacific northwest this is what we
call the ridge in the jet stream and
this ridge has built right over us that
means we will warm up for several days
here and stay hovering right around 80
degrees the next chance for wind and
some cooler temperatures it's not going
to be until we get towards the end of
the week all right so we'll see those
winds kick up a little more on sunday
monday and also tuesday where we could
see those gusts actually up to 30 by the
time we get to tuesday so here's the
forecast 58 overnight
calm and cool
like christian
calm and cool 79 degrees for tomorrow
stay nice guys because our normal 75
degrees or
73 actually this time of year so we're
six above average and get used to that
number because we're going to be looking
at those numbers also throughout the
rest of this week here your neighborhood
75 for tomorrow for someone 78 alionte
81 sunrise man or green valley now those
neighborhoods will be in the 80s 77 for
henderson 76 prompt double sevens also
for boulder city in the afternoon here's
your eight day forecast now all right
like we said hovering right around 80
degrees for several days that's not
going to change all the way through
sunday changes come this weekend with
breezy winds and do don't forget to
switch back the clocks turn back the
clocks also before you go to bed on
sunday night now that it's sweater
weather
sweater
swiss miss get this guy swiss miss is
serving up a side of ugly
i didn't write this they wrote this for
me the hot cocoa maker has released a
limited edition quote ugly christmas
sweater equipped with an insulated
pocket to stash the thermos of cocoa on
the go are you kidding me i'm getting
one
the function over fashion find is
available on uglychristmassweatheal.com
for about 45 bucks no actual hot
chocolate included penny for your
thoughts
if you order it now you might get it for
easter you you read my mind i was going
to bring that up i just got hungry right
now i'm making its way tonight i just
got hot chocolate and now i'm craving
stuff yes you know what okay fine if the
sweaters are on back order yes just
don't mess with my swiss mess because my
swiss miss gets here on time i'm okay
yeah i didn't think the sweater sweater
was that bad looking either no actually
we should get one and do a newscast with
you i got idea you do it first and then
we'll join you out yeah exactly yes
okay right